so what we're going to do
is have a look over essentially if you
want to get the syllabus language for
this and i encourage you by the way i'll
just show you
um this is the syllabus document it's
not it's not a document for you you're
not the intended audience however
there's no reason why you can't read it
and actually i highly encourage all of
you
even if you're not going to become
experts in this that's my job
at least become aware of it and it helps
you understand like what are we learning
what's the sequence have i missed
anything it's a really great revision
tool and i should say as well the
mathematics syllabus is i mean i'm
biased but i think it's one of the most
helpful ones in how detailed it is i
know when i work with other teachers and
they have a look at our
uh syllabus so for example
i hope a lot of this rings a bell when
you have a look at it you're like oh i
forgot the blinds c 2.1 have a look at
those dot points right
in fact if you look closely
some of them are literally exactly what
we've done in class like that first one
says establish the formula that the
derivative of sine is cos and the
derivative of cos is negative sine by
numerical estimations of the limits and
informal proofs based on geometric
constructions that's a bit of a mouthful
but it's literally what we did i gave
you guys that graph of sine x we
informally measured geometrically what
the gradients were and we got a sense of
what the gradient should be and
therefore what the derivative is okay
and you can keep on going all the way
through that we've actually really been
covering you can see that heading there
c 2.1 and we've also been looking at c
2.2 kind of in parallel right
so having come to the end of that that's
why this is my last lesson with you guys
today
i wanted to kind of tie this up in a
neat bow uh you can see i've left off
polynomials like x squared x cubed etc
because we covered that last year we
didn't really need to review that so
obviously you know more derivatives than
just on this page
but i wanted you to have one like six
like single place where you could look
stick this in your book whatever it is
that you want so that we know all of
these things that we've learned over the
last three weeks or so
i started with the easy stuff uh the
stuff that is the uh kind of earliest
that we looked at we're just going to go
through and say what's the deal for each
one and when we have a look at the chain
rule as we make this more complicated
what does it then look like right so
no prizes i want you all to say this
with me on the count of three the
derivative of e to the x is just three
two one
edx thank you so let's just pop that
over here in that first box
now when i say chain rule
what i'm referring to is the fact that
if you do did not have just an x up in
the uh exponent in the index right if
you had something like if you were asked
to differentiate
something like e to the
f of x so i gave you a variety of f x's
over the last few weeks like i could put
an x squared in there i could put a um
x on three i could put anything in there
right we sort of got used to the fact
that we would take that derivative of
that top bit right the derivative of f
which i guess in these terms you would
call the derivative of f of x
you would name that
f
dash
you would find that derivative
and then you would say okay well the
rest of it is e to the power of
something and when you differentiate e
to the power of something as we just
kind of stated nothing changes so you
end up with e to the power of
whatever something was there before
which i guess we're calling f
of x does that make sense so you see
these are really the same rule here on
the left and on the right but this is
what happens when you kind of just take
it to the next level there's a function
of a function you use the chain rule
okay
all right let's see how your memory is
we then extended it fairly recently to
say well e to the x is the nice neat
looking base but we actually can handle
any exponential you like 2 to the x 3 to
the x 5 to the x we just need to modify
what's going on here right so when you
differentiate a to the x you still end
up with something that has a to the x in
it but we modify it somehow do you
remember what's missing
yeah go ahead
okay so i've got the a to the x here and
then we get uh lin or log of a whatever
that number happened to be so if you
were differentiating 2 to the x your
derivative would be 2 to the x log 2.
that's it okay
now going over here to the right we're
going to do it you know row by row if i
then had not a to the x but
if i was differentiating
a to the f
of x
have a think about how it's going to be
different and how it's going to be
similar
when you have a look at the first and
the second row
really the key difference is this log
right it's just off by a different
factor okay so that log is going to be
there again but if you have a look up
here there's also this chain real stuff
happening right it's very very similar
so i can say i'm going to do that
derivative of whatever is up the top
there
you're not in e it's some other base so
i'm going to say that's a to the f of x
and then like you saw over here on the
left hand side that log a just is the
fact that we change by so it's just
going to be trailing along the end there
okay and of course in the case where
your base a happens to be e this will
become exactly the same thing you saw up
above f dash x e to the f x and then log
e this is base e so it's just one
and it just cancels out okay
all right can i just pause there is this
making sense it's ringing bells i hope
okay i know this is a couple of weeks
ago we did this let's move into the logs
this again is a really simple one when
you differentiate base e maybe we should
put that as well this is log
base e of x they're the um different
notations for the same thing
what do you get is the derivative the
really simple one
fantastic thank you very much 1 over x
and then when we extend that into
the chain rule if you've got if you've
been asked to differentiate
log of some function
f
of x
again it bears a lot of resemblance to
that thing over on the left it's still a
fraction so i'll just write that
what's on the top
f dash and on the denominator
it's f of x
so f dash on f that's the way i say this
because it's just a bit
quicker to say but same deal right does
this make sense these are easy results
to use
okay now this one you can see i've given
you a bit of space because we're going
to do a teeny bit of working here right
this is actually sneaky i did kind of
smuggle this into the exercise but i
never did this up on the board so maybe
i should do it with you now
in the same way that we went from e to
the x to a different base a to the x now
i'm doing the same thing but for logs
base e is easy base a you've got to
think a little bit okay so what we're
going to do is as has often been the
case we're just going to make a slight
modification to the way we write the
original function
before we differentiate
this is with a different base
a instead of e so what log law is going
to help me write this in a more helpful
form what do you reckon ishii
change your base law right the base is
not the one we want so i'm just going to
change it okay now we know that it's
easy to deal with if you've got base e
so therefore
when i've got this fraction is what you
get in change of base law right um have
a think about what's going to be on the
top and the bottom does anyone want to
suggest what's going to be for change of
base law on the top and the bottom ian
um
log base e
x or you could write that as ln x at the
top and then on the denominator
log
base e
of a right so you can see we've changed
the base it's now a and e
and the way i remember is that this a
and this x is the same like the lower
one is lower and the upper one is upper
so that's why the a is down here the x
is up there okay
now even though i could use this just
fine just to make it super obvious right
i'm going to write this with ln notation
the constant part is 1 over this log
base e of a
ln
of a that part is just a number right
and then what's on the numerator is
ln
x and i already know how to
differentiate that it's just 1 over x
just i've got a number out the front it
could have been 3 or 4 or 5 but it
happens to be 1 over log a it's an
awkward sounding number but a number
nonetheless so therefore when i
differentiate it
have a look at what we started with up
here
what you're going to get down here have
a think
any suggestions
i'll give you a clue
there's a 1 over x in there
because that one over x right there it
comes from this log x here but then
there's an extra bit what's the extra
bit that i'm going to need
yeah it's this is this one over lna
right so it's really this
times one over lna but because they're
both on the denominator you might as
well just kind of squish them together
uh i tend to see it written like this
one over x log
a i'll just put that over there because
i'm slightly irritated by the symmetry
of it so there you go
that's what happens when you've got a
different base
let's see if we can extend it over here
to when we have chain rule
if i am asking you to differentiate
something a log with a different base
log base a
of f
of x i wonder if we've got enough
information just on the piece of paper
for you to be able to follow the pattern
and tell me what's going
to result
what do you think
i'll give you a clue
there's a fraction
i have i have great like completely
useless clues but that's why i give them
to you so easily um what did you start
with if the bass was e
you have this right in a much the same
way if you look up right do you see how
much similarity there is with
exponentials when the base is e when the
base is not e like things look almost
exactly the same and the same deal is
going to happen here
we had f dash
on f before
and we're going to get f dash on f again
but by adding this different base
well what's the difference
do you see how with exponentials we are
we multiplied by log a remember how
exponentials and logs are the same
things just looked at from different
perspectives so instead of multiplying
by log a what do you think we're going
to need to do
we're going to have to
divide can you see it we've actually
already done this so therefore this is
going to be a log a
but it's on the denominator yeah
okay
that's actually casting your mind back
so i hope we'll be able to do this next
bit a bit more easy because it's quite
fresh right
derivative of sign we actually just
looked at it in the syllabus it's just
going to give you
cos
fantastic
and if i asked you to differentiate not
sine x but sine of some function of x
are you starting to get sick of this yet
it's the same rule chain rule every time
right you're going to differentiate that
part on the inside the f of x
which gives you f dash
and what happens to the sign when you
differentiate it you just told me it
becomes
cos but don't forget it's not cos of x
it's because of
whatever that function was so we will
call that f of x
okay
derivative of cos you'll be careful
because so similar but just slightly
different it's a negative sign
so if i differentiate
cos of some function
that f dash is going to come along for
the ride
at this point i could write the minus
over here but if i factorize it nicely
that minus would actually end up out the
front so that's where i'm going to place
it and then you end up with sine of
whatever that function was
and then we can round it out
tan is the weird one that's because it's
really a quotient in disguise sine over
cos when we did this we actually proved
it what did you end up with we had to
use a reciprocal
sec squared right
sec squared x
so therefore final bit of our summary
when you've got tan of some function
f dash again
and the tan turns into sec squared like
we already saw
[Applause]
now when you have a look at that right
i think it's really important that you
have this summary somewhere that you can
get to easily
however some of you are going to get a
little bit crossed at me because in a
sense you didn't need to write this to
have access to this summary because
can some of you tell me where this
summary already exists
this is let's have a look this is page 3
of the reference sheet right
and you can see on the left hand side
differential calculus right you've got
the uh
familiar stuff like product fill in
question rule up there on the top and
then ta here are actually the results
you've just been working on right there
do they look familiar in fact are they
almost exactly how you've written them
i think it's really important number one
um that you know where these are right
the reference sheet is no advantage to
you if you spend all your time not
knowing where things are so you're like
digging around and it's meant to save
you time but there's a time penalty to
using it if you don't know where things
are okay but secondly even though i know
you have this you can get given it in
every exam i still think it's vital
that you have your own one because
i used to teach a student who routinely
got like in top 10 rankings in every
subject that he did and everyone was
like oh man jason is so smart how can i
be as smart as jason and jason made
assiduous notes things like this and
everyone would say if only i could get
jason's notes i could be as smart as
jason jason wasn't just smart he was
generous so he literally gave anyone who
asked a copy of his notes and it's like
wow isn't that nice
but no one ever did as well in their
tests as jason did can anyone tell me
why
because like reading isn't as effective
as writing down yourself
even if you've got access to the notes
even if you've got every single thing
there reading it's one thing but
actually writing it yourself is totally
different an entirely different thing
happens in your brain and it will help
you actually reinforce this in your mind
so
whichever one you want to go for make
sure you've got it accessible but these
results here it's super important that
you work with them that's how you learn
them not by reading them okay